[音楽]
[拍手]
想像してみてください
もし皆さんがか聴いてだったら読者からのどんな反応を嬉しいと感じるでしょうか
シンプルな言葉を3つ挙げてみます自分が嬉しいと感じるものによかったら手を挙げて
みてください
一つ目面白かった
ありがとうございます二つ目考えさせられた
ありがとうございます3つ目わかりやすかった
はいありがとうございます
今日は3つ目に挙げたわかりやすかった
についてお話をさせてください
わかりやすかったこれ私にとってはあんまり褒め言葉に聞こえないんですね
分かりやすさは確かに一つの価値ではあると思います
でもそう言われると私はこう思ってしまいます
すんなり読めるものですかなかったな
彼らに灯油を残せなかったなって
分かりやすいって本当にいいことなんだろうか
そう考えるようになりました
私はライターとしてフワフワとした世の中の事象を一つの言葉に収めて誰から見ても
明らかな情報に変えることを生業にしています
言葉は大きな力を持ちます
ある時は人を励ましある時は人を傷つけます
言語化能力は武器になりますビジネスシーンでも日常生活でも誰かのモヤモヤを言葉に
すると感謝されることがあるからです
私はそんな言葉の言葉が持つ力にあやかりながらも一方で言語化の弊害を感じることも
あります
分かりやすい言葉は物事の複雑さや変化のための余白を消してしまう可能性があるから
です
私たちはもしかしたら言葉の確からしさを過信しすぎるのかもしれない
人も減少も本来複雑で変化し続けているはずなのに
一つの言葉にあてはめとタムあまりきらなかったほかの要素たちがポロポロとこぼれて
複雑さが失われていくんです
分かりやすいって本当にいいことなんでしょうか
私はライターとしてジェンダーや多様性について執筆をしています
もっぱらインタビューをしているのは世の中の歪みを正そうとするアクティビストや
ビジネスパーソン lgbtq や病気障害を抱えた人が経ち
いわゆるソーシャルマイノリティと言われる人たちを対象に取材をしています
ああああああ
私が記事を書くときに大切にしていることの一つは
白黒つけようとしないということです
生き方に正解はありません
ある人にとっては白でもある人にとっては黒かもしれない
あるいはその中間にグリーンのグラデーションがあるということも忘れてはいけません
こちらの女性彼女は抜毛症という症状と共に生きる
土屋光子さんという女性です
私が大好きなそうだというメディアで書きました
自然に髪が抜けてしまう脱毛症とは違い
抜くという感じも使う抜毛症というのは自分で自分の髪を抜いてしまう症状のことを
言います
土屋さんは髪が生えていると抜きたくなってしまうからと自分で自分の髪をそって
抜毛症であることを公表してきています
どうしてそうしたかというと
直すことを目標にうウィッグで隠し続ける人生に嫌気がさしたからだと教えてくれまし
た
私にとっての正解は私だけが知っているというのがこの記事のタイトルです
直さずに受け入れるというのが土屋さんとっての正解でした
私は彼女のこの選択を尊敬しつつも実際の記事に書くときにはあくまで土屋さんの正解
であるということを強調して書いています
なぜなら直さずに受け入れるというアイディアの対岸にはがんばって乗り越える
というアイディアもあるからです
そのどちらも尊重されるべきなので私は記事が公開されるときには編集担当者さんと
一緒に自分の立脚点が一方に偏っていないかを確かめます
でもそれではどっちつかずの主張になって広く読まれないんじゃないっていう疑問も
あるかもしれません
ここで大切にしていることが2つ目
広く読まれることを目標にしないということです
この読まれるという感覚はあくまで
メディア側の都合なんですね
メディアは読まれるためにいろいろな工夫をしています
例えばタイトル
たくさん並んだタイムラインに並んだ記事の中から自社の記事を選んでもらわないと
いけないので
タイトル付けには苦心します
強い言葉を使えば使うほどクリックされる可能性は高まります
例えば私が書いたもので強い言葉を使ったなぁという自覚があるものがこちらです
フェミニストは男嫌いのブスだと思っているあなたへ
男嫌いブスという強い言葉を使ったからでしょうか
確かに広く読まれました
でもこの考え方が行き過ぎると
クリックベイト問題につながります
クリックベイトというのは
クリックを促すために記事の論旨とは関連性のと星煽るようなタイトルをつけることを
言います
岸お湯をクリックしてみたら内容が薄くてイラッとしたこと皆さんもあるんじゃない
でしょうか
タイトルの他にも例えば長い読み物は途中で離脱してしまうからと相手に戦時経度に
まとめようとしたり
ドラマティックな表現を使ったりいろんなきてがあるんです
でも私最近こうも思うんです人生ってそんなにドラマティックなものだったっけって
最近思うんです
自分自身の話になりますが
私は3年前腎臓の手術を受けました
長年痛みが続いて喜怒哀楽も忘れていたミニスカ目が向かない
そんな生活が長く続いていたので臭突を受けられるということは私にとってようやく
見つけた出口で喜ばしいことだったんです
でもどうしてかその日が近づくにつれて私は回復することの恐怖と戦っていました
逆境に使って成功している人たちの情報を制止しすぎて自分も同じように逆境をバネに
してもっともっと上に上がっていかないと価値がないんじゃないかって思いこんで
しまっていたんです
でも活躍なってしなくったって
静かにゆっくりと自分の家にげない毎日を取り戻すことだって十分価値があったはず
です
わかりやすく貼りなものばかりを摂取していると支えで複雑なものに対する筋肉が衰え
ていくんじゃないかなって思いました
今でもインタビューをしながら相手から power word を引き出そうとして
しまう自分がいます
その人のありのままを受け入れたいと思う自分と
広く読まれるためにストーリーを描こうとする自分の間で揺れています
さてここまで私は書き手としての葛藤についてお話をしてきましたがここからは読み手
としての市政についてお話をさせてください
私は
書くことで情報を世の中に届けています
でも情報は情報のままではあまり価値をなしません
情報の受け手によってそれが噛み砕かれることによって
情報は意味へと変わります
意味になって初めて価値があるんじゃないかなって思うんです
じゃどうしたら意味に変わるのか
それは自分の中に問屋意見があるときです
自分のデータベース経験を通してその情報を眺めてみてください
それから記事を読むときの姿勢としては
ここに書かれているものが全てじゃないという前提をもって読んでいただきたいです
シンプルで短いものが求められがちな胃の中においては言葉はどんどん削られて短く
なっていきます
ここに書かれていない削られたものは何なんだろうということに思いを馳せてみて
ほしいです
それから
この言葉は最終形じゃないということも付け加えます
どういうことかというと言語化されたことによってある言葉とともに世の中に知られた
人物にも将来的に変わる可能性があるということです
先日インタビューをさせて頂いたパレットというウェブメディアの編集長を務める彩
さんがこんなことをおっしゃっていました
私は最近自分のセクシャリティを語らなくなりました
セクシャリティは将来的に変わる可能性があるものだから
ておっしゃったんですね
人は変わります
がんサバイバーはがんサバイバーとしての人間じゃないし
レスビアンは sb あんだけの人間じゃないんです
映画やドラマとは違いいい
登場人物たちの人生も続いています
なので読み手の方々は彼らの人生は続いていて変わる権利があるということを念頭に
おいていただきたいなって思います
それから3つ目
すっきりしないときこそチャンスだということです
記事を読んだり sns を見たりしていてなんだかモヤモヤしたとき
自分の心の中には思いがあります
それを自分なりに咀嚼して
言葉にしてみてほしいですそしてよかったらそれをシェアしてみてください
私は自分の記事が公開されるとどんな風に読まれたかが気になるので sns を探し
に行くことがありますいいいい犬も悪い犬もありますでもそれが考えた末のものである
ことが分かるとなんだか感動するんですね
自分が産んだ意味に対してまた誰かが意味を重ねてくれることで自分の考えもさらに先
に進むからです
そういう意味で読み手書き手というのはどちらかが上というものではなくって相互作用
的でフラットな存在一緒に意味を作り出していくためのどうしたというふうに最近
捉えるようになりました
さて一ノ通りに戻ります
分かりやすいっていいこと
今の私はこう答えますよくもなるし悪くもなる
何とも白黒つけない回答で恐縮ですがやっぱり情報の入り口として分かりやすさは勝ち
になるし
複雑さを消してしまうという意味で注意が必要だと思います
どうしてこんなに言葉との付き合い方にこだわるのでしょうか
それは
良くも悪くも
実体が言葉に引っ張られるという現象があるからです
こんなことなかったでしょうか
なんとなくいいなぁと思っている相手に心の中で
あ私この人のこと好きかもしれないと言葉にしたことで想いが一気に加速したこと
反対に
私この人無理かもしれないと違和感を覚えた相手に対して宣言をしてしまうことでその
人に向き合おうとする自分が筆記にシャットダウンされてしまったこと
言葉には力が伴うんです
茶道して余白にこだわるんでしょうか
それは私たちが多様性を生きるうえで必須のアイディアだからです
一度見つけた自分の正解というのは5年後の正解とは限りません
自分が変化していくとともに答えだって変化していくはずなんです
一度見つけた一つの理想にしがみついていると自分がその理想とは反対の姿になって
しまった時にプロメラーのように自分を苦しめます
そういう意味でた四世を大切にすることを余白を大切にすることというのは人への優し
さでもあり自分への優しさでもあるんです
私はそう信じて答えのない言葉との付き合い方に悩みながら明日もあさっても明明後日
も意味を産み続けて行きたいと思いますありがとうございました
[拍手]